[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission 2022 vue
par vue par le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines pierre bédier
pierre veut dire bonjour bonjour on est
dans votre bureau que vous connaissez
bien compris
je travaille beaucoup oui vous y
travaillez beaucoup et c'est toujours un
plaisir tous les matins comme ça de
revenir l'audio désirer toujours bien
sûr parce que d'abord on est dans un
lieu historique c'est la préfecture des
yvelines devenu et préfecture et conseil
départemental
les conditions de travail sont quand
même très agréable un bureau grand
lumineux et surtout des dossiers
passionnants au service des yvelinois
alors on va parler de 2022 si si je vous
dis comme ça de 2022 quel est le premier
peut-être événement la première chose
qui vient à votre esprit la fin de la
pandémie
l'élection présidentielle la coupe du
monde de foot au cas par les jo de pékin
l'élection présidentielle on sait qu'il
va se tenir pour le reste rien n'est
moins sûr la pandémie on n'est pas sûr
qu'elles finissent les jo de pékin si
j'ai bien compris ça va être pas mal pas
mal boycotter quant au qatar si ça
devrait quand même se tenir à l'est
espérons que la france remporte une
deuxième coupe du monde
à la fi ni la fin de la pandémie on peut
l'espérer mais mais bon je ne crois pas
je pense qu'on va on va être habitué on
va s'habituer à vivre avec ce truc là le
temps que
l'épidémie perdent en virulence
il ya l'eau quête annuelle du cevipof
qui vient d'être sur la confiance des
français c'est toujours des sentiments
d'un peu des passions tristes qui domine
la méfiance
le là où la morosité la lassitude
vis-à-vis notamment de la politique
quand on les interroge sur la politique
c'est aussi la méfiance le dégoût même 1
comment vous expliquez aux forceps
distance qui se confirme quand même
d'étude en étude entre entre les
français et la politique alors après on
viendra cela dit ou aux fonctions qui
sont les vôtres qui sont un peu épargné
la question la question est rude je suis
pas sûr qu'une seule réponse il me
semble que si on pouvait simplifier nos
circuits de décision et en particulier
je crois beaucoup à la décentralisation
c'est à dire la décentralisation c'est
pas des déconcentrations
déconcentration c'est l'état qui décide
de rapprocher ce édition du terrain
décentralisation c'est l'état qui part
du principe que les élus sur un certain
nombre de sujets peuvent faire mieux que
lui et sans doute pour moins cher et je
crois la décentralisation au début de ma
vie politique je n'y croyais pas j'étais
un jacobin comme on dit je croyais la
puissance de l'état et aujourd'hui les
sujets sont tellement complexes de mon
point de vue que si on veut des réponses
pertinentes et rapide il faut accepter
de faire confiance à ceux qui sont les
plus proches des électeurs et à ceux qui
sont en capacité de pouvoir répondre
intelligemment et rapidement et et les
élus locaux ne sont plus les mêmes qu'il
y a un siècle il ya un siècle au début
de la république les élus locaux
s'étaient souvent des paysans qui
n'était pas forcément passer par l'école
qui n'était pas encore tout à fait
répandu même si elle avait commencé avec
jules ferry à ouvrir à des classes
partout dans toutes les campagnes
et donc des gens faiblement forme et
qu'ils avaient besoin du support de
l'état aujourd'hui il suffit de regarder
parmi les 259 merde est évident si
j'étais méchant je dirais que leurs
diplômes additionner doivent être
supérieur à celui de tous les
fonctionnaires de l'état dans le
département donc faisons confiance aux
élus locaux et c'est ainsi que les
citoyens donc les électeurs pourront à
nouveau faire confiance à la politique
parce qu'ils auront le sentiment que
leurs élus peuvent répondre aux
questions du quotidien il ya d'ailleurs
toujours cette enquête s'est vite parce
qu'il ya deux exceptions dans cette
méfiance vis-à-vis de la politique ces
deux fonctions qui sont aimés parler
parler français c'est celle de
conseiller départemental et du conseil
départemental et c'est l'américain c'est
le maire et les élus départementaux
ça peut s'expliquer parce que il ya quoi
la proximité et puis y'a peut-être le
fait que les gens voient aussi la
conséquence des décisions qui sont
prises sans doute plus tu je rajouterai
aussi le fait que les élus locaux on a
été les premiers à sortir dé des combats
idéologiques
il n'y a pas une façon enfin il y avait
autrefois des façons de gauche et des
façons de droite de gérer aujourd'hui il
ya surtout du pragmatisme et je crois
que les citoyens nous en rendre grâce
donc justement je reviens ce que je vous
disais sur la décentralisation c'est
bien la démonstration que plus on va
rapprocher le citoyen du décideur mieux
ce citoyen acceptera le jeu démocratique
il ya aussi le fait peut-être on l'a vu
pendant cette crise sanitaire que les
mairies et les le conseil départemental
on agit parfois dans la carence de
l'action de l'état enfin pour pallier
l'action pour simplifier les l'action de
l'état mais parce que moi j'aime pas
taper sur l'état g je reste je reste
gaulliste donc je crois qu'on a besoin
d'un état fort mais ensuite est ce que
ça fait d'être renvoyé lourd oui mais
justement est-ce que c'est à l'état de
s'occuper de problèmes de masques je
pense que c'est il est plus normal que
ce soit le maire de la commune appuyez
effectivement par le président du
conseil départemental où la présidente
du conseil régional parce qu'il a besoin
de grouper les commandes il a besoin de
s'assurer que les produits arrivent il
faut une certaine logistique ceni au
ministre de la santé nih au premier
ministre ni au président de la
république comme on dit un peu
vulgairement c'est pas de leur niveau
eux ils faut qu'ils s'occupent
effectivement de la vaccination est ce
qu'on met des milliards sur tel vaccin
ou sur tel autre vaccin est ce que on
pense que le médicament ne sera plus
important que le vaccin où il faut faire
les deux ça ce sont des décisions
stratégiques qui relève effectivement de
la sphère état pour la vie quotidienne
pour le concret faisons confiance aux
élus locaux vous souhaiteriez que dans
le prochain quinquennat quel que soit
l'élu qui est d'une nouvelle réforme
justement de la décentralisation je ne
souhaite pas je vais fait plus que le
souhaitez je pense que le pays connaîtra
deux terribles tourments dans le
prochain quinquennat s'il ne fait pas
cette réforme cette réforme
elle est une nécessité absolue il ne
peut pas y avoir de réforme de l'état
dont on voit bien que c'est devenu un
magma plutôt ingouvernable et qui
coûtent de plus en plus cher on nous
parle souvent du déficit de l'état
rapporté au pib on nous dit c'est 100%
6% 7% ce qui paraît finalement assez
anecdotique parlons des vrais chiffres
le budget de l'état ces 450 milliards
d'euros 150 milliards de déficit l'état
est en déficit d'un tiers de 33% mais
c'est considérable pour ça qu'on peut
dire qu'on va vers la faillite donc ne
créons pas d'emplois supplémentaires
mais disons nous bien qu' il faut
arriver à avoir un service public rendu
aux citoyens qui coûte beaucoup moins
cher en sachant qu' il y à des dépenses
nécessaires dans un certain nombre de
secteurs je pense en particulier à la
sécurité
et je ne suis pas de ceux qui pensent
qu'il faut réduire à l'aveuglé les
effectifs de fonctionnaires il faut
réfléchir est ce qu'on ne peut pas
confier à d'autres cartes des
fonctionnaires certaines missions de
façon à pouvoir concentré effectivement
les missions plus essentiel pour
l'autorité de l'état pour l'autorité de
la chose publique en règle générale sur
des fonctionnaires cesser cette
révolution là qu'il nous faut faire elle
passe par la décentralisation donc on
veut dire en gros aux fonctions
régaliennes pour les 1
et laissé l'essai de resto laisser le
reste aux collectivités qui devrait
faire en partenariat quelquefois avec
les citoyens j'ai le souvenir comme mère
est actuellement comme président du
conseil départemental
on passe aussi par la voie associative
pour réaliser certaines missions de
service public on peut même en confier
certaines à des entreprises donc on n'a
pas toujours besoin d'avoir des armées
de fonctionnaires ça ne donne pas
forcément un bon résultat
ayons de la souplesse et surtout sans a
priori idéologiques et ce à la
décentralisation le permettra c'est la
première étape pour avoir un état plus
léger plus svelte donc plus réactif et
donc plus pertinent au service de nos
concitoyens alors pas lors de la
présidentielle puisqu'elle arrive dans
soixante quinze jours on veut près même
pas vous êtes candidat pas pris ça en
corne pas encore mais weirich clp
il ya eu les balles et d'aborder des
primaires puisque il y avait il y avait
deux débats dans les premières ceux qui
voulaient un corps et dont vous étiez
oui et puis ceux qui voulaient primaires
ouvertes finalement c'est le congrès
alors il ya beaucoup de gens qui étaient
sceptiques ou disons ça sera pas
terrible comme nombre de votants par
rapport aux 3 aux millions 4 millions
qu'il avait voté pour fillon en 2010 en
2016 finalement ça a plutôt bien
fonctionné oui d'abord parce que rendons
hommage à celui qui a mené toute cette
opération qui est christian jacot non je
lui fais un petit texto vous savez on
est comme les djeuns non ça va des
petits textos pour lui dire il fallait
un syndicaliste agricole pour arriver à
un tel résultat avec beaucoup d'astuces
beaucoup de malice et beaucoup de
patience il a su tricoter une procédure
qui a fait totalement consensus avec une
idée de génie c'est que le deuxième tour
ne dure pas trop longtemps de façon à ce
qu'ils aient pas de bagarre et à ce que
l'union puisse faire très vite donc je
suis très très très content que la voie
du congrès été choisi après
valérie pécresse une yvelinoise a été
désigné et tout le monde s'est rangé
derrière elle donc c'est pour moi un
grand sujet de satisfaction vous n'avez
pas réparti entre pour le finaliste
emporte valérie pécresse eric ciotti
s'est passée la neutralité président de
l'air qui est exactement comme président
de la fédération j'étais chargé de
l'organisation avec un cabri qui est la
secrétaire départementale
ça me paraissait un peu délicat d'être à
la fois juge et partie donc j'ai pas
pris position premier tour j'ai pas pris
position deuxième tour mais j'avais
indiqués dès avant le premier tour que
naturellement je serai dernière celle ou
celui qui sortirait du congrès que
j'appellerai tous nos adhérents tous nos
sympathisants en faire de même
la coop ou à la santé cette campagne
vous aimez bien les compagnies
j'avais fait un certain nombre vous avez
fait quelques-unes
on a l'impression que ça a eu la drôle
de guerre kinball de campagne cleric sa
part pas vraiment alors peut-être qu'on
attend la candidature du président
sortant mais
voyez c'est vrai que c'est une drôle
alors d'abord bon je crois que la
pandémie on l'a déjà vu l'année dernière
les sélections départementales et
l'année devant avec l'élection
municipale ça rend les élections peu
différente je pense aussi que les
évolutions technologiques membre de
l'ailé campagne mer est très différent
pas beaucoup de choses se passent
désormais sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis le jeu n'est pas encore connue
il ya encore quelques hésitations sur
les candidats en particulier du côté de
la gauche c'est là la grande nouveauté
jamais la gauche depuis 1969
qu'est ce que révèle 68 avec la
candidature malheureuse de gaston
defferre qui avait fait un score
ridicule
la tentative de de mitterrand à charles
et keats et enfin la gauche en 69
étaient totalement décomposés on revit
un peu c'est la période me semble-t-il
ce qui fait qu'on avait un 2e tour assez
curieux puisque c'est un deuxième tour
en train entre la droite centriste et le
centre droit c'est toujours l'hypothèse
où et alain poher donc un truc un peu
spécial du coup une plus faible
participation avec un parti communiste
qui était très fort à partir des
registres des réformes et qui n'avait
pas pris position deuxième tour j'avais
lu claudie bonnet blanc et blanc bonnet
et donc j'ai un peu le sentiment connais
un peu dans cette période un peu de hors
norme hors cote donc c'est vrai que ça
rend cette cette compétition électorale
particulièrement curieuse mais bon voilà
mais il ya eu aussi des périodes où la
pression les gens ont l'impression que
la
présidentielle présidentielle allait
pouvoir changer leur vie au pied de
grandes batailles idéologiques on
attendait peut-être revenu aussi de 7,2
de ce sentiment là c'est vrai que
l'amour lot de la période est moins -
charge et d'idéologie
mais enfin l'action présidentielle reste
quand même pour je pense tous les
français ce qui structure et ils ont
bien compris que c'était le point
essentiel peut-être trop d'ailleurs mais
[Musique]
mais ça rejoint parce que vous disiez
sur le caractère un peu désabusé de nos
concitoyens par rapport à la politique
je pense qu'il pensait qu'avec
l'élection de nobles croyait à l'homme
providentiel
il faut dire aussi que de gaulle nous a
mal habitué le premier président de la
république mais c'est
lui l'homme de la france on pouvait
difficilement faire mieux
après il ya un autre problème qui peut
se poser on voit que les candidats sont
à peu près au dessus ou en dessous de 20
25 % au maximum
comment gouverne avec 20 % à 7 % parce
que et après il faut faire des il
faudrait pouvoir faire des alliances est
ce que le système politique de la vème
république et justement dans pêche pas
qui se structure autour du président élu
n'empêche pas un peu cette alliance que
vous pouvez vous passer par exemple dans
un département oui bien sûr ben alors
après ça renvoie notre
notre système institutionnel j'ai eu le
bonheur il ya quelques semaines
d'inaugurer avec pierre mazeaud que les
téléspectateurs ne connaissent pas
forcément pierre mazeaud cros la liste
de nos très grands juristes il a été pré
grandes familles de les réceptionner et
il a été quant à lui nommé
grant alpinistes 1 et il a été le
premier français sur sur l'himalaya mais
il a surtout été au cabinet de michel
debré au moment de la constitution de la
vème république et donc j'ai pu discuter
avec pierre mazeaud donkey punch mais
grands anciens et lui est totalement
hostile au régime présidentiel à me
surprendront prendre goût de certains il
considérait ce gaulliste
et ils considèrent que c'est une erreur
que en fait il faudrait revenir un
système parlementaire parce que le
système parlementaire permet justement
des désaccords les alliances certains
partiront de l'idée des compromissions
mais le compromis comme lui c'est pas la
compromission
voilà une probable et voilà il faut bien
comprendre que dans une société complexe
dans une société où désormais à par
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
il n'y a plus la même virulence que dans
les années passées il faudrait sans
doute un système un peu plus souple
voilà c'est une piste je vous la livre
comme ça
parce que c'est extrêmement difficile de
faire une réforme qui priverait les
français de l'élection devrait leur
président de la république mais il faut
peut-être rien s'interdire
en tout cas c'est pour moi une piste de
réflexion non votre majorité
départementale
il ya des mères il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont
très sympas qui se profile et pékin et
puis à des mères importants qui se
prononcent pour emmanuel macron est ce
que ça vous pose un problème non je
choisis pour qu'il y ait pas d'ambiguïté
de soutenir valérie pécresse mais
les emmanuel macron n'est pas un ennemi
de la république il est président de la
république
donc c'est un adversaire un son
adversaire
disons que c'est une vision différente
il n'y a pas de détestation il n'y a pas
de combat à proprement parler et je
considère pour ma part que ces
grands-mères
mrs
on quitte à fait le droit le maire de
poissy ont tout à fait le droit de
choisir dans ce cet espace de modération
un autre candidat ça ne nous empêche pas
de nous retrouver au conseil
départemental dans la majorité
départementale est en parfaite harmonie
en parfait accord sur bien des sujets on
n'est plus du tout vous évoquez la
puissance du parti communiste dans les
années 60 donc on n'est plus du coût du
tout dans ces clivages
terrible ou même 1980 l'arrivée de
françois mitterrand au pouvoir ou la
caricature voulait que les chars russes
débarquent place de la concorde
assez vite d'abord on a vu qu'on était
bien loin je crois que c'est d'ailleurs
un des avantages de cette alternance
c'est que ça a permis will apaisée c'est
ce qu'ils apaiser le faire que on
comprenne bien encore une fois dans dans
le cercle républicain
toutes les opinions sont acceptables
sauf les opinions extrémistes qui de par
la violence qu'elles génèrent ne peuvent
pas être dans le cercle de la raison
républicaine il vous auriez un
vice-président au fait quelqu'un qui se
prononceraient pour
marine le pen pour eric zemmour ce
serait plus compliqué très compliqué
comment pourrait-on admettre que mes
vice-présidents soi et mauricette alors
que monsieur zemmour explique qu' il
faut que les enfants handicapés n'avait
plus à l'école avec les enfants non
handicapés alors que c'est exactement
inverse de la politique qu'on mène dans
le département où on essaye nous mêmes
selon ce mot que j'aime pas beaucoup
mais que j'utilise par commodité mais
c'est d'être inclusif nous mêmes donc on
voit bien que ces extrêmes ne
connaissent pas la réalité des
situations il oublie surtout que
derrière des situations sont pas des
généralités qu'on trouve ce sont des
visages de femmes d'hommes d'enfants
et qu'il faut donc leur donner le
meilleur et le meilleur passeport de la
modération alors on va parler des
yvelines de début de 20,2 vous avez des
drones dont on veut je vois que les
yvelines reste ce département où il fait
bon vivre ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que les yvelines c'est une histoire
extrêmement prestigieuse ce bio
est à la préfecture la préfecture et à
versailles et versailles c'est la
première ville nouvelle de france on a
reçu une ville moderne rationnelle
autour du château tout à fait
remarquable donc des villes il n'y a pas
de versailles mantes la jolie est une
ville nouvelle du moyen-âge donc un peu
moins rationnels saint germain en laye
est une est une ville exceptionnelle
rambouillet les villages sont
exceptionnelles donc tout toute la trame
urbaine du département des yvelines est
exceptionnelle mais elle s'appuie sur
des paysages exceptionnels donc c'est
notre histoire c'est notre géographie et
aujourd'hui quand on voit vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure la pandémie on se
rend bien compte que nos concitoyens ils
cherchent cet équilibre entre la ville
et la campagne ils ont besoin de
services seule la ville fournit des
services
mais ils ont aussi besoin d'espacé les
yvelines département de l' équilibre je
sais de l'expliquer quand je parle de
modération politique je dis aussi d'
équilibre d'aménagement du territoire
cet équilibre cette modération qui est
le la marque yvelinoise je souhaite de
toutes mes forces qu'elles perdurent en
tout cas notre action politique celle du
conseil départemental va dans ce sens là
l'une de vos fierté c'est d'être à la
tête des départements le mois des
banquiers de france alors le moins
dépensiers de france pour ce qu'on
appelle pour que nos concitoyens
comprennent bien les dépenses de
fonctionnement les dépenses de
fonctionnement c'est les dépenses
courantes justement ici le trend vie
faut peut-être faire la défense va là la
différence entre les dépenses de
fonctionnement une jeune homme investi
exactement et dans un département pour
que l'on puisse investir beaucoup parce
qu'investir c'est assurer l'avenir
construire comme on le fait quinze
collèges ou les recontres en bois en
bois enfin en bois en bio sourcés comme
on dit chez shell et sachant pas ce que
ça peut être autre chose que du bois
mais d'une façon donc beaucoup plus
écologique
développer on va donner accès en cinq
six ans à tous les enfants des collèges
et avant des enfants de l'école
élémentaire ou tablettes numériques pour
mieux apprendre donc tous ces efforts là
comment peut-on le faire on dépense le
moins possible dans les dépenses
courantes y'a pas de luxe ici pas de
luxe inutile les voitures de fonction
que sais-je et cetera tout ça s'est
réduit au minimum du minimum en
contrepartie de quoi on a des excédents
sur 7 ce fonctionnement donc la
différence entre nos recettes et nos
dépenses et tout cet argent un excédent
permet de faire de l'investissement il y
a hélas beaucoup de départements qui
quand ils ont fini de faire leurs
dépenses courantes il ya plus d'un an
regarde donc ils peuvent pas investir et
ça notre fierté dans les yvelines ça
être que depuis 25 ans sonné le
département le moins dépensé en dépenses
de fonctionnement moins dépensé de toute
la france et ce qui nous permet d'être
arrivé à être pour la première fois le
département qui en était déjà depuis
quelques années qui par habitant dépense
le plus sale l'investissement mais
désormais même en volume 1 nous sommes
le département qui est le volume
dépensent le plus en investissement ça
pourrait être un exemple ça pour la
gestion d'état parce qu'on dit souvent
oui mais je sais pas si évident je suis
d'accord avec vous mais je ne serai là
quand même pas candidat à la présidence
de la république je sentais la peine que
vous
donc dans les investissements il ya
notamment 200 millions pour les
universités ou pour la recherche
la médecine aussi un
concrètement ça veut dire quoi 200
millions pour ce secteur ça veut dire
que l'intelligence en fait ça veut dire
qu'on accompagne des projets nouveaux ou
des projets existants donc l'université
on accompagne très fortement sciences
politiques à saint germain en laye parce
qu'elle
l'institut d'études politiques de saint
germain forme les cadres de demain des
cadres à la fois publiques et privées
donc
7,7 mutti absolument extraordinaire pour
préparer l'avenir vous évoquez la
médecine on est en pleine réflexion sur
la création de munich d'une part dont de
nos petites halles numérique sur le
développement de la télémédecine donc
l'idéal serait effectivement d'avoir
pour faire que les habitants se
déplacent ce - ce qui est
dans les nécessités d'aujourd'hui pour
éviter la pollution qu'on puisse avoir
un certain nombre de consultations
médicales fait par des sommités n'est
fait en télémédecine et pour ce faire
qu'on est en valeur un hôpital de mairie
ce qui n'empêcherait pas l'hôpital
physique nous on aura toujours besoin de
soigner les gens mais pour tout ce qui
est diagnostiquée on doit pouvoir grâce
à la technologie à condition d'investir
avoir des conditions d'égalité de soins
pour tous les illinois il ya d'égalité
de soins pardon performant pour tous les
élus
dont parlait de déplacement il ya le
question deux écoles là aussi vous
investissez pourquoi alors et hall qui
est le prolongement de la ligne e eole
qui vient de la seine et marne qui
traverse paris qui s'arrête aujourd'hui
à saint lazare qui ira jusqu'à mantes la
jolie desservant toute la vallée de
seine et qui va permettre de
restructurer cette vallée de seine qui
depuis trente à quarante ans ne connaît
que le déclin économique lié aux
difficultés de l'industrie automobile
mais nous avons aussi le tram 13 qui va
de versailles
jusqu'à cacher et on l'espère un jour
jusqu à cergy pontoise donc nous
participons au développement des
infrastructures de transport en commun
il ya aussi la hume 18 à travers la
société du grand paris
donc
des infrastructures de transports
collectifs les infrastructures de
transport par la route alors je sais que
certains s'y opposent en disant mais non
on veut pas de route on veut pas de
route si on veut des voitures il faut
bien avoir des routes on peut pas avoir
l'un sans l'autre alors un jour en plus
projetons nous toujours
un jour l'automobile elle sera plus
polluantes
l'énergie je pense que l'énergie
électrique est indispensable mais de
façon transitoire l'énergie sera sans
doute avec l'hydrogène
l'intelligence artificielle appliquée à
la voiture va sûrement produire du
covoiturage en plus grand nombre on sera
propriétaire à plusieurs d'une même
voiture pour faire ces trajets
professionnels donc il y aura beaucoup
moins de monde donc projetons nous vers
l'avenir qui aurait cru
à part le département des idées d'où ce
conseil départemental qu'un jour nous
serions un département où le vélo serait
un moyen de déplacement pour aller au
travail personne pourquoi parce que à
l'époque beaucoup de pentes de gens
n'imaginaient pas que rhin jour le vélo
électrique or le vélo électrique changer
surtout parce que aller à son boulot en
vélo si vous faites du 10 km heure et
c'est à à 15 km vous mettez une heure et
demie en vélo électrique vous allez
mettre 20 minutes
et ça reste quand même sportif parce que
vous êtes vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'utiliser toujours d'électricité donc
les évolutions croyons à l'avenir à
travers la science 1 0 lyon
technologique nous permettent de mieux
aménager le territoire un désaveu du
site vous reparler de l'automobile et
c'est un des départements des grands
départements de l'automobile et les
yvelines c2c le changement de l' usine
de flins qui va devenir une visite de
2,2 dès que tu es sûr qu'il soit là
parce que je crois que vous appelez ça
un facteur factoriens c'est ces
anglicismes
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'économie si la
secte biais qui était solution qu alors
peut on rêver par le conte récupère des
voitures et on les reprend par on leur
redonne un coup de neuf mais ce qui est
en train de se faire pour les vêtements
ce qui se fait pour les téléphones donc
nous allons aller largement vers cette
économie circulaire et c'est une très
bonne chose et je suis très fier que les
yvelines ne soit en pointe dans ce
domaine je vous confirme effectivement
que redoux
à des objectifs très très ambitieux sur
son usine de flins ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle il ya au projet de verdissement
justement des aides enfin souci
écologique dans l'est oui dans les aides
oui c'est quoi votre concept de
l'écologie au fond
parce que parfois ccc on voit bien enfin
cdh et écolo c'est c'est moi de dépenser
moins ça c'est une autre vie enfin un
autre c'est pas forcément la seule au
septuor écologique qu'on peut avoir je
pense que si l'écologie répressive
malgré sa nécessité elle n'obtiendra
aucun résultat parce qu'elle
elle sera même un ferment de révolution
ce que sont les plus modestes qui
emporteront le poids il faut donc une
écologie même malgré l'urgence
une écologie d'accompagnement une
écologie de persuasion une économie une
écologie de modification progressive des
comportements et c'est pour ça que
toutes les institutions doivent
s'engager il n'y a pas que les
entreprises il ya aussi les institutions
et des institutions doit pas attendre
seulement de l'état nous les
départements les régions les communes
les intercours on doit vraiment avoir le
souci écologique
soyons lucides on va pas du jour au
lendemain faire régresser le
réchauffement de la planète qui est un
facteur incontestable
ça va prendre du temps
il faut donc s'y engager avec énergie
avec force et encore une fois j'insiste
bien il faut pas être régressive si on
nous explique que seule la décroissance
nous en sortir à ces poussées l'humanité
au suicide collectif moi je pense je
suis convaincu que par la science
nous arriverons à trouver des solutions
qui ne seront pas des solutions
régressive et qu'ils ne feront pas que
certains vivront plus mal que les
générations précédentes ça ne serait pas
acceptable
vous êtes souhaiter bonne année aux
élèves des doigts ce que vous êtes vous
même souhaitez des voeux
pas mal qu'est ce que vous répondez à
une bonne santé voilà je suis c'est mon
côté
très rurale donkey vinoy la santé
d'abord le reste viendra ensuite
merci de m'avoir sautez donc une bonne
santé merci beaucoup merci et bonne
santé à vous aussi merci à tous les
yvelinois
[Musique]